Sometimes Brady and Neal do experiments that are just for
fun. And then they asked me what's going on?
So the experiment they decided to do was to drop a piece of
burning iron wool.
This is finally divided iron wire.
That looks a bit like my hair slightly darker,
and you can light such iron will by putting it
across the terminals of a small battery and it glows red.
And you can see it burning in the air, not very vigorously,
but enough to stay red.
And.
Then they dropped it into Neil's favorite
cauldron in which he often puts liquid ox
When they dropped it in. And they did it several times.
That were the most amazing colors.
Essentially in all of it. The iron burns,
it didn't all burn because at the end there were bits of iron
left in the bottom. The chemistry is very simple.
The iron is reacting with oxygen.
Okay.
Three oxides of iron,
F E O F E two Oh three and Effie three
Oh four heaven knows which one was formed in these reactions.
And it was properly a ghastly mixture of them.
But the formation of all of these is highly exothermic.
It gives out a lot of heat.
So you have iron going into the liquid oxygen,
producing a lot of heat. And because it's so hot,
it produces a lot of light. In essence,
what was happening is that you have small pieces of very hot
iron in liquid oxygen.
And they were really beautiful colors.
A reaction like this is not very reproducible because it
depends exactly where you drop it, how the light is reflected,
where Brady was standing when he took the shot.
So every picture is different and nearly all of them,
a really beautiful liquid oxygen is a low temperature
minus 186 degrees centigrade.
And you're dropping in a piece of hot metal
and you would expect that metal to down, but it was getting hotter.
The obvious interpretation,
if you see these pictures is that somehow the iron is
burning in this really cold liquid, but that's a contradiction.
How can something be very hot and very cold at the same time? Now,
what I thought was that the iron was so hot,
that it was effectively in a bubble of oxygen gas, which can,
was bubbling up all the time,
but was able to sustain the combustion.
But you can't really see that from top because you're looking through liquid
oxygen.
So we decided we needed to do another experiment looking at
this vessel sideways. So you could see the liquid.
And at the same time,
you could see the iron at the bottom and see what was happening.
But experimentally, this is not easy.
The first problem is that liquid oxygen is very
cold.
So the air contains water vapor,
which can condense an ice. The whole thing up very quickly.
You could get round this by using a transparent,
do have flask thermos, flask, but they quite expensive.
And the last thing you want to do is support whole metal inside it and crack
your favorite thermos vessel. And because these are evacuated,
if they do crack, they will explode spectacularly,
which might make a good video,
but it's unfortunate if it's an expensive piece of kit.
So after discussion with Neil,
we decided that the best thing to do was to use an ordinary beaker
and to put it in a plastic box,
the one he'd carefully made and try and fill the box with either oxygen or
nitrogen,
which would not condense the experiment was
moderately successful.
What I was hoping to see was the iron going in,
sitting on the bottom and burning, surrounded by babbling gas.
[Inaudible].
Of course, what happened is that when it went in,
there was such a bright flash.
It was pretty difficult to film though.
Brady used some quite good tricks to get round this,
and we couldn't get rid of all the ice forming.
Okay.
But the other thing which we hadn't thought about was that the reaction was
so violent that burning bits of iron would push it out of the
beaker pretty quickly.
And they landed on Neil's favorite plastic box
and set fire to it.
It wasn't actually the plastic, but it was the silicone sealant,
which caught fire.
I didn't think that silicone burnt very much at all,
but when you see what happened to Neil's box,
we had demonstrated beyond doubt that when you have an atmosphere of oxygen,
silicone burns pretty well.
And I'm sad to say that Neil's box may be ruined.
It's certainly not in a good state,
but what was particularly surprising to me was that the iron
had got so hot that it'd actually gone through the
glass of the beaker
and effectively punched a hole through.
When we looked at the cauldron,
we also found lumps of iron in the bottom
Because the molten iron was hot and started forming
larger lumps.
And these larger lumps have a smaller surface area.
So they don't burn so fast and eventually they cooled down and the reaction
stops.
And you could tell that they were lumps Irvine,
because you could pick them up with a magnet.
So what's the message. Well, it's obvious our experiment failed.
We did see something,
but we're still arguing what exactly we saw.
And I don't think we can produce a really neat explanation of what happened.
So we've got to get back to the drawing board and design a better experiment.
The film we have taken has had such nice footage,
particularly in the cauldron that we really wanted to show it to you.
And I think it's really important to stress that when you're doing science,
not every experiment works and you can
still enjoy experiments that fail.
And so enjoy our failure.
Very nice object. Now, Steve, I have the impression you think,
you know what this is, this has got to be a Davey land. If you're a superhero,
that would be your thing. That would be me. Yeah. I hate to think, well,
my origin story would be, but, um, there's a second picture here.